zurück bei bild live mit neuigkeiten zu
dem amoklauf in heidelberg eine attacke
in einem hörsaal das ist im moment die
nachricht die durch deutschland geht und
es gibt neuigkeiten in diesem fall ein
großeinsatz der seit jahr rund einer
stunde läuft dort in heidelberg an der
universität nachdem ein mann dort in
einem hörsaal um sich geschossen hat
haben wir jetzt erfahren von der polizei
dass dieser angreifer getötet wurde
schauen wir einmal drauf auf diese
breaking news am montagnachmittag
amoklauf also in diesem 1 hörsaal an der
heidelberger universität im neuenheimer
feld liegt das dort wer die heidelberger
uni kennt und mehrere menschen sind dort
verletzt worden durch eine langwaffe wie
es in polizei sprache heißt also
offenbar durch eine pistole durch ein
gewehr möglicherweise lange wurde das
gebiet dort abgesperrt wie gesagt ein
großeinsatz der polizei und dann vor
wenigen minuten kam die nachricht der
täter ist getötet wurden ob er sich
selber gerichtet hat oder die polizei
ihn getötet hat das werden uns gleich
werden ihnen gleich unsere reporter
sagen die mittlerweile dort am tatort
eingetroffen sind wir schon einmal auf
die informationen die uns die polizei
gegeben hat sofort gab es nachrichten in
den sozialen netzwerken vor allen dingen
auch studenten die dort von der tat
getwittert haben aber dass die
offiziellen informationen von der
polizei dort in heidelberg von der
polizei mannheim also die sehr frühe
unterrichtet hat über diese großeinsatz
lage dort polizei rettungskräften mit
starken kräften vor ort wir halten euch
auf dem laufenden das hat die polizei
tatsächlich dann auch getan wie gesagt
vor wenigen minuten kam dann diese
information dass es sich um einen
einzeltäter dort handelt und dass der
täter selbst tot ist das also die
entscheidende nachricht der stunde der
täter der hinter diesem amoklauf von
heidelberg dort in der universität
heidelberg steckt hier sehen sie noch
mal wie es dort vor ort sieht der ist
mittlerweile tot und wir sprechen mit
patrick knapp mit dem sprecher der
polizei in mannheim der uns gleich erst
zugeschaltet ist so lange wollen wir mit
unseren kollegen bild-reporter
maximilian kiewel sprechen magst du
kannst mich sehen und hören und sag uns
einmal hast du schon informationen
darüber wie der täter ums leben gekommen
ist also hat die polizei ihn getötet
oder hat er sich dort am tatort selbst
gerichtet hast du schon informationen
dazu also ich glaube es gibt erste
meldungen die wir davon sprechen dass
sich dieser täter dieser einzeltäter
womöglich selbst gerichtet hat aber wie
so oft in solchen lagen die
informationen die ändern und wechseln
sich da im minutentakt deswegen hier
muss man sicherlich auch passen wichtig
aber natürlich die information er ist
tot wichtig auch die information du hast
es gesagt hat eine langwaffe eingesetzt
also hat mutmaßlich mit einem gewehr um
sich geschossen mehrere leute verletzt
und ja ein amoklauf mit einer
schusswaffe in einer deutschen
universität das ist natürlich etwas
dramatisches und auch etwas was für die
polizei natürlich alles andere als ein
alltag ist sondern eben eine ganz
besondere eine ganz besonders
gefährliche situation ja du als polizei
experte als kopf unseres teams achtung
verhandlungen max beschreibt uns einmal
was da in solchen momenten abläuft da
kommt die erste meldung hier ist eine
gefährliche lage gerade an der uni in
heidelberg hier gibt es offenbar einen
amoklauf und was läuft dann an was es in
diesem konkreten fall dann angelaufen ja
die polizei die hat vor einigen jahren
dort ihr einsatzkonzept verändert früher
der hätte der erste streifen angefangen
universität zu umstellen und hätte dann
eben auf ja spezialkräfte gewartet die
dann in die uni rein gehen dann hat man
aber herausgefunden weil so
schrecklichen amokläufen wie in
winnenden wie damals in thüringen dass
das ganz viel zeit kostet und vor allem
menschen leben kostet und deswegen ist
in den letzten jahren die polizei der
normale streifendienst darauf
sensibilisiert worden und trainiert
worden in so einer lage in das gebäude
reinzugehen nicht abzusperren nicht
abzuwarten weil eben dort sekunden bei
menschen die entscheidenden und das ist
natürlich gewöhnliche streifenbeamte
wenn man das so sagen kann eine absolute
ausnahmesituation
aber auch da sind die beamten nicht nur
vorbereitet worden sondern in den
letzten jahren auch ausgerüstet worden
in den bundesländern bei den
landespolizeien da haben die polizeien
im kofferraum mittlerweile schusswesten
helme teilweise auch sturmgewehre oder
maschinenpistolen um eben in so einem
moment gerade wenn man es mit einem
attentäter mit einem terroristen der
selbst mit einer langwaffe arbeitet und
zu tun hat dass man da entsprechend
geschützt ist und auch entsprechend
verdienen kann das sind alles dinge die
sich verändert haben in den letzten
jahren wo man schmerzhaft auch
dazulernen musste wo man auch gesehen
hat was bei zum beispiel
terroranschlägen in brüssel in paris
passiert ist und daneben in der folge
das eigene konzept umgestellt hat vielen
dank maximilian bleibt noch einen moment
bei uns wir berichten an diesem
montagnachmittag über einen amoklauf an
der uni in heidelberg in einem hörsaal
hat ein mann um sich geschossen offenbar
gibt es mehrere verletzte der täter
selbst ist tot das ist das was die
polizei uns vor wenigen minuten gemeldet
hat und wir sprechen jetzt mit dem
sprecher der dortigen polizei mit
patrick knapp der uns am telefon
zugeschaltet ist schön gut tag knapp
guttenberg also das ist erstmal eine
entwarnung die wir ihren twitter
meldungen entnehmen ist das so das ist
richtig wir hatten hier vor ort einen
vermutlich einzeltäter der mit einem
gewehr einer langwaffe mehrere personen
verletzt hat
über die anfangen können wir noch nicht
sagen wir gehen von einem einzeltäter
aus der einzeltäter
verstorben können sie uns etwas sagen
über die opfer unsere gedanken sind
natürlich bei denen bei denen die
verletzt wurden heute bei dieser
schrecklichen bluttat orte im hörsaal in
der heidelberger uni was sind das für
verletzungen und können sie uns etwas
sagen zu ungefähr 1 anzahl der
verletzten nein da können wir noch
nichts darüber sagen weder zur
personenanzahl noch über die art der
verletzung jetzt haben sie gerade war es
diesen großeinsatz an vorsichtig
entwarnung geben können was können sie
uns über den täter sagen und hat er sich
dort am tatort selbst gerichtet auch das
bedarf weiterer ermittlungen
wir haben hier alles großflächig
weiträumig abgesperrt und durchsucht und
das ganze gelände einfach um auch auf
nummer sicher zu gehen aber im moment
gehen wir davon aus dass es eben dieser
eindruck geht an dollar können sie etwas
sagen zu der örtlichkeit also klar
heidelberger universität aber lief dort
gerade eine vorlesung war dort gerade
eine veranstaltung wie waren die
örtlichkeiten genau das bedarf alles der
weiteren ermittlung aber das gelände
hier ein klick und universitätsgelände
ja
dann danken wir für diese erste
nachricht noch eine kurze nachfrage zu
ihrer twitter-meldung langwaffe was
können wir uns darunter vorstellen
wahrscheinlich ein gewehr an im kern
genau richtig
ein gewehr wir danken für die ersten
informationen von der polizei in
mannheim von der polizei in heidelberg
die sehr umfangreich schnell informiert
hat in diesem fall diesem amoklauf dort
an der universität in heidelberg
sprechen wir weiter mit meinen kollegen
maximilian keyword im kopf unseres teams
achtung fahndung wir hören von diesem
amoklauf eben haben den polizeisprecher
augen der uns von diesem großeinsatz
berichtet hat ihr c ich maximilian noch
nicht aber kommt sicherlich gleich noch
mal zu uns wie ist das in solchen bei
solchen groß gefahrenlagen wie behält
man da den überblick es muss ja
wahnsinnig schwer sein für die
polizeieinsatzkräfte die möglicherweise
auch erst mit einzelnen streifenwagen
dort ankommen und dann so ein großes
gelände und eine völlig unklare lage
sehr schnell sehr richtig einschätzen
müssen
ja der einsatz wird natürlich
koordiniert über die leitstelle aber du
hast vollkommen recht die informationen
die sind ja spärlich am anfang da heißt
es dann ein mann ist unterwegs mit waffe
da schießt jemand um sich und mehr
informationen haben die polizisten in
dem augenblick ja nicht das heißt sie
arbeiten sich dann vor wahrscheinlich
selbst mit mit mit pistole mit
maschinenpistole im anschlag oder
zumindest in und dann hat man dieses
riesige gelände wo man nicht weiß es ist
ein täter sind es zwei täter sind es
noch mehr in den vergangenen jahren
haben wir in so lagen immer wieder
erlebt dass die ursprüngliche aussage
ist es ein täter nicht gestimmt hat oder
wenn von mehreren tätern gesprochen
wurde am ende ist doch nur einer war
also diese ersten informationen sind
ganz oft auch nicht dass man sich darauf
verlassen kann sondern hast ein riesiges
gelände wo theoretisch überall ein
eingriff an angreifer stecken kann und
dann muss man sich davor arbeiten muss
kommunizieren weiter mit anderen beamten
muss sozusagen absperren von außen eine
ganz ganz schwierige situationen eine
situation die die polizei immer wieder
übt aber da muss man sich nichts
vormachen training und übung ist immer
das eine wenn du am ende weiß du gehst
jetzt in einem hörsaal und irgendwo in
diesem uni gebäude ist ein mann der hat
ein gewehr dabei und schießt um sich ist
das natürlich noch mal was völlig
anderes lass uns noch einmal gemeinsam
darauf schauen auf das was wir wissen an
diesem montagnachmittag zu dem amoklauf
in heidelberg der sich also vor rund
anderthalb stunden dort abgespielt hat
ein großeinsatz der polizei von mannheim
von heidelberg ebendort an der
heidelberger universität am neuenheimer
feld mehrere menschen dort verletzt
worden dass die informationen der
polizei gerade nochmal hierbei bild live
auch bestätigt die anzahl der verletzten
noch nicht weiter präzisiert zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt durch eine langwaffe
also durch ein gewehr wie der
polizeisprecher patrick knapp gerade bei
bild live auch gesagt hat ein gewehr
also mit dem dieser täter dort um sich
geschossen hat der tatort das haben sie
gerade an den bildern auch gesehen er
ist weiträumig abgesperrt da kommt man
im moment gar nicht ran dort an die
universität und der täter und das ist
ganz wichtig und das bedeutet
tatsächlich vorsichtig entwarnung dort
für diesen amoklauf heute in heidelberg
der täter ist tot unter welchen
umständen er ums leben gekommen ist
getötet wurde ob er sich selber
gerichtet hat oder von der polizei
möglicherweise erschossen wurde das ist
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht klar die
ermittlungen laufen noch der
polizeisprecher wollte dazu gerade keine
stellung nehmen maximilian kiewel kopf
von unserem team achtung fahndung weiter
bei uns ist weil wenn wir die ganzen
bruchstücke die ganzen bausteine jetzt
einmal zusammensetzen
worauf lässt diese tat schließen hast du
irgendetwas schon über die hintergründe
des täters gehört wir hören jetzt nach
ersten informationen er soll selbst auch
student dort an der heidelberger
universität gewesen sein genau wie die
kollegen der dpa haben gerade eine ein
nachricht verschickt und sagen drei
wesentliche informationen ist soll sich
bei ihm also um einen studenten handeln
und es gingen nach aktuellen
informationen keine infos darüber vor
dass es einen politischen oder einen
religiösen hintergrund dieser tat gibt
also womöglich ein persönlicher
hintergrund das glaube ich eine ganz
wichtige information die jetzt gerade
eben verbreitet wird die jetzt gerade
über die nachrichten ticker läuft keine
politische keine religiöse motivation
sondern eben jemand der persönliche
beziehungen zu dieser universität hatte
weil er selbst dort als student war
wobei wir auch bei diesen nachrichten
sehr vorsichtig geworden sind maximilian
muss man auch sagen es gab bei vielen
vergangenen taten sehr schnell eine
sogenannte entwarnung dass es keine
terrorattacke und später hat sich dann
doch noch ein terroristischer
hintergrund
herausgestellt also wir nehmen diese
erste informationen sehr wohl zur
kenntnis hier gibt es offenbar
persönliche hintergründe für diese tat
diesen amoklauf in heidelberg aber
tatsächlich die ermittlungen natürlich
die beginnen jetzt erst in diesem fall
danke maximilian für den moment wir
sprechen jetzt am tatort direkt mit
unserer kollegin bild reporterin janine
wollbrett die dort ist auf diesem
gelände das mittlerweile weiträumig
abgesperrt ist aber schön sagt uns
einmal was du im moment sie ist dort
noch am tatort im moment ist natürlich
alles abgesperrt mehrheit über uns ein
hubschrauber greifen also und die
menschen sind ja ziemlich geschockt
stehen da also nochmal information muss
es aus sich auch um einen
biologiestudenten gehandelt haben
näheres nähere infos hat er leider nicht
also wie gesagt alles was mich
eingesperrt auch die stadtrings roma
kommt kaum hierher überall stau und wie
gesagt über uns ein polizeihubschrauber
du hast gerade gesagt die menschen dort
sind schockiert was ist da los aktuell
auf dem gelände also waren dort etliche
vorlesungen strömen die menschen dort
weiterhin raus aus der universität
beschreibt uns dass ein wenig er die
stecken die stehen ja teilweise um die
wünsche nach den vorlesungen haben es
irgendwie stehengeblieben es gibt aber
auch menschen hier ist ein riesiger
klinikkomplex auch dir irgendwo in
station war draußen waren und neugierig
sind es gibt auch viele schaulustige die
er extra her gefahren sind deshalb auch
der stau ringsrum so muss man sich das
nicht vorstellen
was spielt sich jetzt am tatort ab also
wie viele einsatzkräfte sind noch dort
und wie viele rettungskräfte
möglicherweise denn zu der zahl der
verletzten wollte der polizeisprecher
gerade bei uns soll er konnte noch nicht
dezidiert stellung nehmen also es müssen
schon mehrere verletzte gewesen sein
denn schon auf dem weg hierher kanne
viele viele ambulanzen rettungskräfte
gegen steht auch nokia
ganz viele deutsche rote kreuz wegen
sind her und aber schwer einzuschätzen
da mehr nicht reinkommen da kommt nicht
mehr ran ist es möglich großräumig
abgesperrt danke für die ersten
eindrücke dort vom tatort bild
reporterin janine wollbrett an der uni
in heidelberg und weiter wieder mit
maximilian kiewel dem moderator unseres
format achtung fahndung noch einmal
unsere zuschauer in einen solchen
großeinsatz mitzunehmen schreibt uns
doch einmal amoklauf an der uni
heidelberg was passiert in solchen
momenten bei den einsatzkräften
am allermeisten kommt es also auf die
polizisten an die als allererstes am
tatort eintreffen sie sind diejenigen
die dann sich im kopf auch darauf
vorbereiten müssen gleich auf den
attentäter zu treffen und diesen
amoklauf diesen terroranschlag denn auch
das wissen sie zu dem zeitpunkt ja noch
nicht was ist hier der hintergrund das
zu beenden und zwar so schnell wie
möglich also am ende vielleicht auch in
eine situation kommen zu müssen wo sie
auf den angreifer schießen müssen das
sind die dinge die ablaufen im kopf dann
hat man es hier zu tun und die
heidelberg wir haben es jetzt schon
mehrfach gehört ein riesiges gelände
verwinkelte gebäude große flächen also
ganz schwierig zu übersehen zu
überblicken und in dieser lage arbeiten
sich dann die polizisten vor mehr die
einsatzkräfte treffen natürlich ein
probieren über funk miteinander in
kontakt zu treten zu koordinieren wer
geht in welches gebäude von wo kommen
eigentlich zeugenaussagen wie bringen
wir die menschen hier raus und das also
in möglichst kurzer zeit denn in so
einer lage geht es wirklich dass er jede
sekunde über leben und tod entscheiden
kann sind unsere einsatzkräfte deiner
meinung nach für sowas gut geschult das
ist eine ganz schwierige frage die man
glaube ich pauschal auch nur ganz schwer
beantworten kann es gibt bestimmt viele
viele viele polizisten die mental
vorbereitet sind stark genug sind für
einen einsatz auch wo es auch zum
selbstverständnis gehört dass man in so
einer lage
ja eintritt für für menschenleben da ist
für andere um sie zu schützen auch wenn
das im schlimmsten fall bedeutet dass
ich mein eigenes leben riskieren aber ob
das für jeden einzelnen polizisten in
deutschland so geht ich weiß es
schlichtweg nicht man möchte einfach nur
hoffen dass wenn man in so eine
situation kommt wenn polizisten zu so
einem ort gerufen werden sie in der lage
sind mental aber eben auch von ihrem
ausbildungsstand von dem was sie im
kofferraum dabei haben was sie selbst in
so einem moment schützen kann und soll
dass sie fähig sind in so einer
situation gut zu bestehen und am ende
auch selbst gesund vor allem da wieder
rauszukommen
maximilian lasst uns schauen noch mal
auf das was wir wissen über diese
über diese bluter diesen amoklauf von
heidelberger am heutigen tag also die
nachricht kam vor ungefähr anderthalb
stunden reihen es gibt dort eine bluttat
an der universität in heidelberg und das
ist der aktuelle nachrichten stand also
das ganze spielt sich ab an der
heidelberger universität dort am
neuenheimer feld mehrere menschen sind
dort verletzt worden durch diese attacke
durch eine langwaffe und das können wir
schnell übersetzen das hat die polizei
nämlich gerade hierbei bild life
bestätigt es handelt sich um ein gewehr
also ein einzeltäter ganz offenbar der
dort geschossen hat auf mehrere
studenten dort in der heidelberger
universität und mehrere auch verletzt
hat wie viele wissen wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht wir wissen derzeit nicht
wie viele menschen bei dieser bluttat
verletzt worden klar ist dass der tatort
sofort weiträumig abgesperrt wurde dass
das ein großeinsatz von polizei und
rettungskräften heute war und ganz
wichtig ob das hat die polizei hier
gerade live bestätigt der täter selbst
ist mittlerweile tot unter welchen
umständen er getötet wurde das oder sich
selber gerichtet hat das ist derzeit
noch unklar dazu hat die polizei noch
keine stellung genommen wir haben
mittlerweile maximilian kiewel bei uns
vom team achtung fan-block ein paar mehr
informationen über den mann der der
täter sein soll nämlich welche genau
also nach aktuelle nachrichten stand
nach den aktuellen meldungen die uns
vorliegen dann gibt es in diesem
konkreten amoklauf momentan zumindest
keine hinweise darauf dass der angreifer
politische oder religiöse motive hatte
sondern es soll sich um einen studenten
handeln der in einem hörsaal eben
studenten angegriffen und schwer
verletzt hat das haben wir gehört also
womöglich persönliche motive aber du
hast vorhin vollkommen zu recht gesagt
das alles ist noch sehr früh die tat
liegt anderthalb stunden zurück da muss
man einfach noch abwarten was sich da
weiterentwickelt dass der täter mit
einer langwaffe mit einem gewehr
bewaffnet waren das ist schon etwas
besonderes was sozusagen negativ
besonderes in deutschland denn das kommt
nicht so häufig vor warum weil lang weil
waffen generell in deutschland schwer zu
bekommen sind schwer in die hände zu
bekommen sind gott sei dank
das ja das sicherlich etwas ist was
aufhören lässt wo man schauen muss wo
hat er diese waffe her mit der er am
ende um sich geschossen hat da gab es in
den vergangenen jahren in deutschland
unterschiedliche ja wie gründe die
menschen an diese waffen gekommen sind
ob es die jäger sind ob es sportschützen
sind ob die waffe illegal gekauft wurde
zb im darknet ob vielleicht jemand die
waffe selbst hergestellt hat wie damals
der rechts terrorist der die synagoge in
halle angegriffen hat da gibt es also in
den vergangenen jahren unterschiedliche
schreckliche beispiele denn klar wer mit
einer langwaffe um sich zielt und
schießt der kann unglaubliche wirkung
unglaubliche verletzungen auslösen und
das sicherlich etwas wo die polizei
genau hinschauen wird was war das für
eine waffe und wo kommt sie her gibt es
da hintermänner wo genau hat er die
besorgt hier sehen wir eine solche
langwaffe oder solche langwaffen
vielleicht beschreibt uns einmal was wir
dort gerade auf den fotos sehen max also
ich glaube die informationen momentan
die sind noch zu spärlich um genau zu
definieren um was für eine langwaffe ist
sich hier handelt und wie gefährlich
dann diese waffe auch ist denn es gibt
natürlich die unterschiedlichsten typen
von so einem gewehr mit dann auch ja
unterschiedlicher gefahr die davon
ausgeht also handelt es sich zum
beispiel um eine automatische waffe kann
der in sehr kurzer zeit sehr viele
kugeln von sich schießen und damit
natürlich auch sehr viele leute treffen
oder muss jeder einzelne patrone neu
eingelegt werden neu geladen werden was
dann sehr viel mehr zeit dauert in den
usa sehen wir immer wieder dass
amokläufe mit eben halbautomatischen
oder vollautomatischen gewähren
stattfinden mit diesen unglaublichen
opferzahlen am ende wo viele viele
menschen dann getötet werden eben bei
diese waffe weil diese waffen so brutal
sind das wissen wir alles noch nicht wir
wissen nicht genau welche waffe es sich
handelt und welche waffen typ es sich
handelt und das wird ganz sicherlich ein
ganz wesentlicher teil der ermittlungen
jetzt sei das herauszubekommen und
natürlich geht es um das warum
herzlichen dank maximilian kiewel aus
dem team achtung fahndung über dieses
warum wollen wir sprechen mit dem
facharzt für psychiatrie
beantragen wollen der mir zugeschaltet
ist hier am montagnachmittag bei bild
leicht nach dieser schrecklichen bluttat
von heidelberg schönen guten tag herr dr
rocken wollen wir fragen natürlich nach
dem warum nun ist es zu früh da eine
antwort in diesem speziellen fall in
diesem aktuellen fall zu geben aber wir
fragen uns das natürlich bei jedem
amoklauf wie kann das überhaupt sein
dass menschen wahllos auf andere
menschen schießen welche erklärungen
kann es für so etwas geben
die erklärung sind
unterschiedlich es gibt natürlich
menschen die sich auf irgendwelchen
gründen radikalisieren aus religiösen
oder politischen gründen und dann auf
diese schreckliche art versuchen ein
zeichen zu setzen oder einfach auch nur
zu vernichten
um sozusagen die macht ihre ideologie
damit zu zeigen
gibt allerdings auch in den letzten
jahren ja gesehen
auch nicht so welten
einzeltäter die
entweder
erfüllt sind ihre gedanken haben einfach
oder auch ganz manifest zügig strang
finden zum beispiel und im grunde hängt
die motivation im einzelfall sehr
unterschiedlich eins ist aber klar meine
derartiges herrn zu begegnen muss man
auf jeden fall eine aggression schwelle
überschreiten die man normalerweise
nicht überschreiten wir haben jetzt ein
paar bausteine die möglicherweise ihnen
schon informationen darüber geben was
das für eine art von täter sein könnte
also offenbar einzeltäter offenbar
student dort an dieser universität
offenbar ja vorbereitet also er hat ja
ein gewehr bei sich gehabt und offenbar
hat er ja mehrere schüsse daraus
abgegeben es soll mehrere verletzte
geben und er selbst ist tot hat sich
möglicherweise selber gerichtet oder ist
erschossen worden das heißt hat offenbar
auch den eigenen tod dort mit
eingepreist möglicherweise
weist er daraufhin
nicht unbedingt in der sich etwas
erkrankung ist das sind meistens leute
die eher sozial randständig leben wenn
das jemand ist der akt die studiert hat
dann wird jetzt zumindest eine gewisse
leistungsfähigkeit gehabt haben so dass
man eher ideologisch politisches
religiöses motiv vermuten könnte aber
das sind zum jetzigen zeitung natürlich
reine spekulation oft sind es ja leute
die sich ausgeschlossen gescheitert
ausgegrenzt fühlen und auch sehr wohl
einkalkulieren noch dann am ende um
gebracht zu werden im zeitablauf was ich
damit sozusagen in einem inferno und
ihrem leben ein ende setzen sollen aber
wie gesagt da finden jetzt für den
einzelfall absolute spekulationen
darüber liegen glaube ich nicht
informationen vor danke für diese erste
einschätzung dennoch herr doch trocken
weil nur noch eine frage natürlich mit
blick auf die opfer auf die verletzten
dort die heute schreckliches erleben
mussten wie bekommt man und bekommt man
überhaupt jemals solche bilder eine
solche tat aus dem kopf wieder
herausführten gesehen es gibt leute die
sind dann buchstäblich schwer
traumatisiert und bleiben daran hängen
ziehen sich zurück
verlieren deutlich soziale kompetenz
dadurch und auch möglicherweise nicht
mehr arbeitsfähig andere menschen die
relativ unbeeindruckt wind sowie mehrere
überfälle mitbekommen haben und im
grunde ihrem alltag relativ
unbeeindruckt nachgehen ganz sicher kann
man nicht sagen was denn die faktoren
sind die eine schwere beeinträchtigung
nach solchen taten nachrichten gott
verlangen kann man sagen das ist nicht
so dass jeder 100 prozent invalidität
durch den eindruck einer ruhigen tag
letzte frage doch trocken weil er solche
taten sind die er von langer hand
geplant amokläufe oder ist das ja eine
kurzschlussreaktion meistens keine
kosten für uns hängt damit zusammen dass
wenn man gern gefährlich besorgen muss
eine langwaffe wie schon gesagt wurde
ist nicht so einfach zu besorgen in
deutschland das muss man vorbereiten man
muss sich positionen besorgen und
letztendlich natürlich auch überlegen
wie man nicht im einzelnen plant
das sind in aller regel keine
kurzschlussreaktion das sind taten die
etwas länger vorbereiten will danke dr
bernd rocken wollen dafür diese ersten
informationen einschätzungen facharzt
für psychiatrie nach diesem
schrecklichen amoklauf heute in
heidelberg dort in der universität
darüber sprechen wir weiter mit meinem
kollegen maximilian kiewel vom team
achtung fano wir sortieren noch einmal
ganz schnell für unsere zuschauer max
was wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wissen
über diese bluttat als die nachricht kam
rein vor rund anderthalb stunden dort
aus heidelberg wir haben gehört relativ
schnell von der polizei dort dass es
sich offenbar um einen einzeltäter
handeln soll der dort in einem hörsaal
um sich schießt und mittlerweile können
wir für sie auf dieser tafel die
informationen also zusammentragen
amoklauf im hörsaal an der heidelberger
universität also das ist jetzt wichtig
der täter selbst ist mittlerweile tot
und die polizei geht deswegen auch
vorsichtig entwarnung dort in dieser
gefährlichen lage an der heidelberger
universität der mann soll selbst student
gewesen sein dort auch unsere kollegin
janine wollbrett bild reporterin dort
aktuell am tatort ja gerade gesagt
offenbar biologiestudent dort an der
heidelberger universität das sind die
ersten informationen unserer reporter
und es sind mehrere menschen dort
verletzt worden durch schüsse durch ein
gewehr dass der täter bei sich gehabt
haben soll mittlerweile heißt es sogar
mehrere gewehre soll er bei sich
getragen haben wir haben solche fotos
gerade gesehen von diesen langen waffen
von denen die polizei aktuell spricht
und ganz wichtiges soll sehe ich bei
diesem amoklauf bei dieser tat um kein
politisches und kein religiöses motiv
handeln mag es also das heißt hier
handelt es sich nach allen informationen
die wir bisher haben offenbar nicht um
einen terrorakt so zumindest die
aktuelle informationen ganz genau ich
finde eine information die du gerade
auch zu recht betont hast noch ganz
wichtig wir sehen also mehrere gewehre
hat er dabei gehabt und das spricht
natürlich schon für einen gewissen ja
logistischen vorlauf für eine gewisse
vorplanung denn mehrere gewehre die hat
man ja nicht einfach so im kofferraum
liegen und fährt damit in die
universität sondern hier hat eventuell
dann doch jemand über einen längeren
tatzeit über längeren zeitraum diese tat
vor geplant die ja am ende eben mehrere
menschen dann schwer verletzt hat aber
das sicherlich sehr relevant mehrere
langwaffen dabei da wird sich eben die
frage stellen wo kommen diese waffen her
wie ist er an die waffen gekommen und ja
wie konnte er am ende dann eben du hast
es gesagt die frage nach dem motiv was
hatten am ende auch überhaupt dazu
gebracht auf andere studenten im hörsaal
sitzen die da gerade eben einer
vorlesung zu hören auch die zu schießen
das sicherlich die großen fragen die in
den nächsten stunden und dann aber auch
tagen und wochen die ermittler in
heidelberg und in der region dann
beschäftigen werden ja man wird jetzt
relativ schnell wahrscheinlich neue
informationen über den täter über den
mann der selbst am tatort also
verstorben ist sammeln können aber vor
allen dingen sind unsere gedanken in
diesen minuten natürlich bei den opfern
bei den verletzten bei den angehörigen
bei all denen die diesen amoklauf heute
miterleben mussten da an der uni in
heidelberg und zur stunde unsere
reporterin janine wollbrett hat das ja
gerade auch berichtet natürlich schwer
unter schock stehen